[Music]
oh yes zlatan versus
lebron are you familiar with this yes
zlatan ibrahimovic is a legendary soccer
player has played soccer at the highest
levels and dominated at the highest
levels i don't know if he said it
won a championship per se did he win
with barcelona's guy in the world cup
no that was inner dean's a dumb okay
yeah yeah frenchman this guy's swedish
well he's he's like yugoslavian right
immigrant to sweden right
sweden really tough life grew up poor
street kid
found salvation through soccer so he's
not like some rich swede who's just
yapping off right and he's
like one of the most cocky people on the
planet and very charismatic and love he
jokes a lot yeah people love him yeah
charismatic um and he basically told
lebron
uh shut up and dribble yeah but he said
focus on what you're good at either you
shouldn't be involved in politics don't
say things about politics we'll get up
in a second you should you look like
him a little bit i'll take it you look
like you slapping you do
yeah so uh and then he basically says
focus on what you're good at which is
obviously the sport
don't involve yourself in politics
because you don't know about it right
and obviously the knee-jerk reaction is
you know i you know lebron is i'm do i
do my googles i'm research i know what
i'm saying blah blah blah but i have
noticed a transition
in how lebron frames his activism post
nba china issue right because lebron
used to do what a lot of people do when
they become activists which say
basically say uh what is it uh
inequality anywhere is a threat to
equality everywhere yeah or injustice
anywhere is a threat to justice
right that's the quote martin luther
king yes and they take that
and they take that premise and they
attach it to everything and then they
have to be an activist
for everything yep and everybody's a
hypocrite
if you go further enough down the line
right like everybody has the phone
it's made by the slaves everybody has
the clothes that are made by the kids in
the sweatshops we're all
hypocrites you can't be a total activist
you can't be a total vegan a total
animal rights activist because an animal
has been doing something for you and you
are connected to that abuse of that
animal or that
human being right right so after the
whole china thing comes out i think it
almost
reminds lebron that like oh there's
certain things that he's okay but
there's certain inequalities that he is
a hundred percent okay about right for
the right amount of money
right like four millions of dollars
treat chinese people however the
[ __ ] you want right is basically what he
said right and
then his focus kind of evolved to i just
care about my community and i'm a stand
up for my community
which i don't knock because i love that
it's literally the only
real way to be an an advocate or an
activist
without getting too much pushback if you
go i'm for equality over here
immediately you get dice apart if you go
yo i just ride for my team
that's all i care about i know there's
other people out there who got [ __ ] up
they gotta ride for their team and get
people to ride for them
but i can't solve all the world's
problems i just gotta solve mine
i honestly think that's the safest
position to be it's the safest but isn't
there a point in which it's like yo they
got
[ __ ] concentration camps over there
like that's not
you could be quiet about some crazy
injustice yeah but what's lebron going
to do about that
especially if same city does say
something
yeah but the the nba makes a lot of
money in china it's part of his contract
he probably can't say anything
yeah you know i guess what i'm saying is
like once you check that corporate money
dog you can't have a podcast anymore
these are all come on man it's that
we're all joking i mean you know
it was it was it was a mutual decision
move walking nah but for real he don't
have faith in the moonwalk anymore he
gives up
why did i think i was gonna have to ask
him a question to get it out just let
him talk about other topics he keeps on
bringing it back
no but seriously isn't it kind of the
same thing it's kind of like he
he works for the nba yeah the nba makes
a
trillion dollars in china everything
makes movie business
there would be no money in rocks movies
as it was everything makes money in
china
yes because that's where the money is
that's where the growing middle class is
that's where everything is made
that's where the tiger mom philosophy is
that's where all the stem research is
being
they're just crushing us we don't want
to admit it yet no no we're jordan on
the wizards dog
stop stop he stop stop you're acting
crazy demi lovato stories make me think
giannis is right
we're not going nowhere we're not going
[Applause]
nowhere
you